all right so this is the party's over I
see no Rita I probably said that wrong
with you just do it this is one of our
Ice King ghosts particularly creepy
opening even for ice these favors
talking about like you for watching
bubble gum as she's leaves a it's like
it don't worry out to get at my house I
mean ia like takes her mouth shut and
like she wakes up knocks him down and
like you know tells him to go away he
thinks like he's coming to an
emotionally mature decision by saying if
you look into your heart I tell me to go
away I'll go away she says go away so he
throws himself in the banana guards arms
and questions didn't shake out of the
way that's like their one up here that
takes it's one of my favorite scenes oh
now she's locked up Jiggs air fins like
Ice King get up and he just pushes buddy
goes I'm leaving so he goes to he wants
to go faraway stars live over anew and
comes across an island that's a lady and
she is dating the the party God who we
just saw was it two episodes ago yeah so
it's a he's back and it's not very good
relationship he just goes off and
parties and doesn't pay attention him in
her form this nice relationship and he
convinces her to break up with him after
they have this giant sky fight and but
fighting the sky sky fight and he goes
and makes the breakup a lot easier by
taking his knocked out head and kind of
force it not forcing but allowing her a
chance to break up with him which I like
at first I thought he was gonna try and
break up with her but I like that he
sort of coaxed her and to say you know
don't you want to maybe break up with me
did a really cool friend tell you how to
be emotionally mature blah blah blah ah
sorry when you said sky fight I just
keep thinking of pie fight from home
movies let's have a pie fight fight
fight
sorry God what okay so that's also a
good show you should check it out
but yeah so if she says you know she's
like oh you're just like my emotionally
mature friend Ice King and Ice King gets
inspired to go and break up break up
with bubblegum he goes breaks up with
her for all the reasons that the island
broke up with the party God and does
even wait for her for the cars to come
in takes off and he just says we'll work
it out so you know a large part of me
like I like a lot of this I love the
idea of a person being an island I think
that's just cool you know I love I love
just what he said Wei sees the outline
and everything it's just I don't know it
was just funny it was creative what if
the anyone was ticklish uh she would
laugh Aloha nothing's wrong with
laughter but Alan doesn't move well then
she would die of laughter but that's not
such a bad way to go hey where would it
kill and to the water a giant islands
are like mini Islands yes I'll just say
yes okay so their problem solved um so
so I love that aspect um I like him and
her sort of forming this relationships
are these two strangers and they both
giving each other advice on
relationships um I like that she follows
through I don't know if I like that he
doesn't truly follow through and they
still like you know we'll work it out
and stuff it's like I you know at the
very beginning of this while he's trying
to kidnap evils again on the saying to
myself you know I'm starting to finally
just get a little tired of this it's
sort of like you know okay can we get
something else and then the episode
starts to do something else and I'm
really thinking like oh my god like is
is Ice King and the island somehow gonna
actually be like a couple or sounds like
how would you even do that I'm thinking
the pots of fili how would you bring the
island to a party or whatever like this
could be really funny and then you know
you sort of leaves
quote-unquote breaks up with bubblegum
but then says we'll work it out which
you know is opening enough to keep going
and I don't know is that like just the
endless tragedy or is that just getting
really old are you asking and in your
opinion yeah your opinion it's how many
Super Mario Brothers games have you
played okay that pisses me out - I'm
sick of rescuing that bitch okay no okay
but that's my thing is that I'm I got
sick and tired of rescuing you know
Princess Peach after like the fifth game
the thing is though is that that's what
people get used to and I do like in at
least Adventure Time where people's
fights back he tries to capture people's
but he very rarely does um so I mean I
think it's more or less just his set
attempts to get her but he never really
captures many of them for the most part
I meet does they get away either pretty
easily everything Jake are they worth it
sometimes I stay like I love when they
stay from our selfies yeah no I I bow
this is not a big fan of this episode
not even like this one no it kind of
dragged for me you know the battle with
the party got dragged a bit I thought V
there's one or two cool things I like
freezing the cloud and having a hit his
head but I was like this could have been
a little funny what about him hooking
him into space yeah I love that I'm
going to space now haha I mean like that
was fun I mean it was there's an okay
episode it was just kind of like that I
guess so I mean I guess what this
episode really after our last episode
the sooner this episode really kind of I
had a different take on it I guess at
this point in time why do you think
people's just the way she is after will
say at least we'll say four hundred
years of non-stop
Ice King trying to kidnap her and guys
consistently trying to date her
I think someone after that much time
would become emotionally detached never
want a date
probably I mean that's I don't think she
looks at most people as humans or
sentient beings I think she's
disconnected so much thinking about it
she woke up to ice king duct-taping her
mouth I mean I noticed she doesn't even
like it doesn't take her long to react
to it she guards that's kind of creepy
think about it she's so used to this
that it really barely faces her you know
something I did a trio watching the
beginning of this and I thought back to
like the first couple of episodes of
adventure time yeah I thought and I said
she is a little different like I think
that the first season she was searches
everything so he's kind of happy and
jolly and now it's a little bit of
service it's sort of like the annoyance
has finally set in with her you know
it's like and yeah she does sort of see
everything kinda like as a mathematical
problem it's not emotional problems like
a mathematical problem it doesn't mean
she's totally devoid of emotion or
anything but yeah there does sort of
seem to be this kind of this distance
I'm thinking back to the yeah the sooner
episode yeah especially I mean she
treated that even though yrt is like a
little tear at the end or something you
know it's like it's still very much like
it's this mathematical problem and I
have to look at it this yeah or else
nothing will get done or I'll get too
involved and I'll fall apart or other
people fall apart that's not good for
them so Plus also okay so the guys been
waiting from a sooner the guy's been
waiting 300 years that tells you about
at least minimum how old Peebles is hmm
okay
so again putting up with this crap for
so long I think she finally got to that
point and Ice King I like him and
everything but I don't know this one I
was just kind of like yeah with it
didn't strike a chord one way or another
and I was just also imagining I guess
when you know the party God comes down
and he's rooting around in her bushes
first stuff it's like does that mean she
doesn't clean herself or she's not able
to bathe that's about it that's the
first thing that comes in your mind when
you hear
going around in her bushes really well
okay what's this oh that just washed up
on me so she can't actually clean
yourself no that's disturbing I guess
would want to know someone like that
okay but she is an island I mean really
that your biggest concern because you
can't move and that she poops smaller
islands no that's not a concern that's
just a question oh I still don't yes
well still I just don't think she'd be a
really good girlfriend at all she
doesn't move she obviously doesn't bathe
I mean but she's got such a likable
personality and even that's kind of
half-assed no I thought it's part of it
though like the face you could no no the
fact that she couldn't get past it was
hard for her to break up with the party
god um I sort of saw like you know
because she can't move because you can't
get do anything I think she does her
thing well what better can I do so I
kind of like that but I like their still
also Canada's confident that just you
know she'll still talking the Ice King
fine it's not like you know oh my god a
person or something like that she's just
hi how you doing so yeah oh no so now
with this girl being like ample
territory for like fat jokes even though
she's not actually fat she's probably
probably the normal size of that I was
saying every woman was an Iowan that's
about what I said but with this did also
bring up because I I think this is a
fabulous isn't a thing but if that there
are like whatever there's like a fetish
for people that like we're just about
the the giant women and that like oh
like that's a big one I mean like
literally Jack and Beanstalk giant and
I'm just thinking like if that is the
thing that's like this episode is
probably watch a million times by those
people depending on how big that fan
fetish base is so yeah that's the thing
you look at me all odd because I'm
wondering how the sentient being poops
and you're talking about people you're
like well if I do want dater how would
she poop how was she cleaners I
I think I would go for this person cuz
there was a possibility I would go for
this giant person that's just too much
sand in your vagina well that is a
constant problem for a lot exactly so
but that's you're obsessed with whole
giant Jack and the bees I've no other I
don't know how else to call I just call
them Jack in the Beanstalk
cuz there are like real you know like
giant people but they're not like the
size of a building or something so it's
like I just called them Jack and the
Beanstalk Giants cuz nobody thinks like
oh that's just a person that's really
tall no Jack it's actually
thought about like technical woman that
could potentially be where I get attack
of the movies yeah no I know but oh
where it started
oh like the whole thing you're talking
about obsessions and all that stuff you
only bringing up cartoons well okay I'm
sure okay it could have started there
into the Giants the TV show a dental
movie but okay touch off subject um that
looked like it hurt really it's a remote
okay so yeah uh I like I mean I didn't
think of someone or anything but I liked
I I thought I was creative enough um it
was okay it just doesn't really stick
out too much in my mind
another question again odd he finds the
radio which barely like hangs on to his
teeth but then he finds the batteries
for the radio which is like the size of
his mouth I was kind of wondering that
too how did they and yes I know tiny
little animation error and all that
stuff but I'm just like that's how like
you know actually what I think it was
more than anything we're never gonna see
her again not to give anything away I
have yet to see her again and it's felt
like one of those episodes where we're
gonna meet a character we're gonna find
out about this character and they're
never gonna return
I I really I would like to see yoga I
would like to see a relationship between
the Ice King and her because I don't
know how it would have I just don't know
how they were doing how it happened but
it would be funny I think it would
actually be a cue relationship but like
just what like other ones where I
believe seen a character and I haven't
seen that come back I still can imagine
them coming back in some regard ah this
one is just like because no one knows
where she is
except for the Ice King yeah so I don't
know it's just I guess that's what it
felt like to me oh look we got a new
character that we're never gonna see
again I like to see her again but I just
to see how they would do it like how
they would you know if he was like I
said to bring it to a party or something
like how would he just bring a little
bit of the sand or herb the mouth or
something he'll like go to her oh there
you go yeah being on her belly seat
that's already a great idea don't follow
up bring her back yes because I have a
feeling Pendleton ward and then make
sure you watch this every single episode
I'm sure they do but is it an episode